bonjour véronique le floch secrétaire
général de la coordination rurale merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous cet après midi
sur rt france alors on l'a dit dit
guillaume appelle les français sans
activité à aider les agriculteurs
est ce que c'est c'est un soulagement
pour les agriculteurs bonsoir tout
d'abord alors oui les agriculteurs ont
un besoin de main d'oeuvre surtout en
cette période de l'année
vous m'entendez allez-y continuer oui
excusez moi donc en cette période de
l'année que ce soit en élevage ou au
lait les travaux des champs on va battre
leur plein mais pour ça il faudrait des
chauffeurs et les chauffeurs comme l'a
dit tout à l'heure le secrétaire général
des transports
tous les chauffeurs sont occupés donc
c'est un souci dans ce côté-là et du
côté de la filière fruits et légumes qui
fait beaucoup appel en général à la main
d'oeuvre étrangère oui il y à ce besoin
de main d'oeuvre
maintenant il faut se poser la question
pourquoi en temps normal on a recours à
de la main d'oeuvre étrangère
le métier il sera le même qu'auparavant
donc nous ce que nous avons besoin ce
sont des gens volontaires motivés nos
exploitations ne sont pas des terrains
de jeu ce sont des entreprises des
secteurs économiques est indispensable
pour tout le monde
donc ceux qui veulent bien se rendre
dans nos exploitations doivent se faire
connaître et bien entendu dans ces
conditions il faut des mesures
exceptionnelles de la part du
gouvernement
nous exploitons sommes déjà suffisamment
bouleversé avec la crise avec la
quantité de travail qu'il faut nous
simplifier le recrutement de ces
personnes volontaires et comme je le dit
motivé mais on n'est que le floch
comment va pouvoir tout simplement
s'organiser 1,7 cet élan de solidarité
bah disons que j'ai vu déjà des sites
qui se met en place
j'offre des emplois je recherche d
emploi mais qui qui ne fonctionne pas ou
qui ne semble pas fonctionner maintenant
les démarches peuvent très bien se faire
auprès des syndicats et nous la
coordination rurale recevons déjà des
appels
ils sont recentrés centralisée au niveau
national mais on les réoriente vers vers
les différentes régions et départements
c'est un souci de recrutement et les
exploitants que nous sommes n'avons pas
envie d'avoir des soucis ensuite avec
ceux qui viendraient travailler sur nos
exploitations
donc là encore à situation
exceptionnelle mesures exceptionnelles
il faudrait que toute responsabilité ne
repose pas sur l'exploitant en cas de
pandémie
nous avons même communiqué pour que des
tests puissent est fait en priorité pour
soulager certains certaines personnes
souhaitant venir travailler sur nos
exploitations mais voulant et de
rassurer avant de démarrer donc bien sûr
nous sommes preneurs de cette main
d'oeuvre
je le répète une nouvelle fois motivé
pour travailler et ayant compris les
enjeux et étend la dent dans le bon sens
pour justement assurer
l'approvisionnement en produits frais
pour tous les citoyens
alors le premier ministre a annoncé hier
la fermeture des marchés ouverts 1 sauf
contrôle de la part des maires ou des
préfets c'est une encore un coup dur
pour le pour le monde agricole
disons que oui c'est pitoyable même si
les démarches peuvent être faites
maintenant par les maires avec l'accord
des préfets ces lieux ne sont pas plus
sain sécuritaire que les grandes
surfaces à partir du moment où toutes
les consignes de sécurité sont
respectées
sachant plus que les commerçants ont mis
où ont pris des dispositions pour
protéger leurs produits
c'est ce sont des marchés de plein air
les gens y circulent
ils vont vite font leurs emplettes et
c'est pas là que sont les plus grands
risques
ce que vous avez peur aussi
potentiellement de ne pas pouvoir
écouler des stocks que vous avez déjà
alors le problème des stocks c'est qu'on
ne les connais pas au niveau des grandes
entreprises les stocks qu'ils soient en
viande bovine ou porcine ou en produits
laitiers ne nous sont pas communiqués et
ils sont difficilement trouvable sur les
sites du ministère
maintenant le problème il est plutôt
pour des petits producteurs qui continue
chaque jour à transformer leurs matières
premières en produits je pense à ceux
qui font de la transformation en fromage
les débouchés habituels sont les marchés
pour grande partie donc la solidarité et
le message porté par certaines grandes
surfaces pour vendre en priorité des
produits français doit être suivi
d'effets donc on appelle on en attend au
moins que ces grandes surfaces se
rapproche de ses producteurs pour les
aider à écouler leurs produits merci des
marchés bien sûr merci beaucoup
véronique floch pour toutes ces
précisions je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général de la coordination
rurale merci beaucoup